(overlapping chatter)
(sirens blaring)
(honking)
- [Interviewer] All right.
- Okay. (chuckling)
- [Interviewer] Kenzie?
- Mm hm.
- [Interviewer] Kenzie, where
are you from originally?
- Phoenix, Arizona.
- [Interviewer] Phoenix,
you've been out here how long?
- About four, a little over four years.
- [Interviewer] Four years.
- Hm mm.
- [Interviewer] What
were the circumstances
that got you down here?
- Hm, I actually was
brought down from Phoenix by
a guy who I later found out was a pimp.
He...
Brought me down here,
promised me that like I was
gonna live in a nice house
and like he was gonna
take care of everything
and I'm a heroin addict and he was like
I can give you all the heroin you need.
And then I was like, cool
and he had a few other girls with him
and they were like,
yeah everything's great
it's fine, it's fun.
And then, so we drive down.
And end up in Compton,
I still don't remember
the exact streets but
he pulls up to this like shack house
like shanty house, like they
had in like New York City
during like the Great Depression.
Like it's made out of like..
Big pieces of wood like
nailed together and like
this like tarp as a roof and like
the first thing that I noticed
was like that there was...
the lock on the front door was backwards.
And then all the locks in
the rooms were backwards.
They didn't lock from the inside,
they locked from the outside.
And then like, I was like,
so I'm starting to get
sick, like what's up
and then, that was first time he hit me,
he slapped me across the face and he said,
bitch, I don't know what you think this is
but this is not like, I'm not giving...
You aren't given anything here.
He was like, I'm gonna take you over
and I'm gonna put you on the
corner and you're gonna work.
And I said, okay...
Um, all right.
And I just knew I was...
And from there I was
in really big trouble.
- [Interviewer] How old were you then?
- Uh, I was about 22.
I stayed with him for
about two and a half weeks,
with him like, just giving
me a little taste of the dope
here and there, really sick.
All my money I gave to him every night.
Any time I like...
He just beat the crap out of us
every time he just felt like it
or he was upset or he thought
we were being disrespectful.
Like, he was just a
horrible, horrible person.
He would lock us in the
house all day, all night
until he wanted us to go work
and then take us out over to Van Nuys.
And then, about two and
a half weeks into it,
I got into a car with an
undercover police officer,
turned out to be and I
ended up getting arrested
off Sepulveda and Victory in Van Nuys
and..
I went to jail and I never saw him again.
I asked the girls in jail
where I could get heroin really easily
and like, where I could go and
they told me how to get downtown,
to downtown Los Angeles and
I just remember getting off the train
and being really sick and
walking up four streets
and seeing the tents and being like
What is going on?
What the he... whoa!
This is insane.
- [Interviewer] It's crazy.
- Hm mm
and I've here ever since.
- [Interviewer] Had
you ever picked up guys
to make money before you met him?
So that was....
- No, I --
- [Interviewer] An introduction.
- Yeah, I was just walking
down the street in Phoenix,
just like, I don't know,
just screwing around
with my friends, I think.
- [Interviewer] But,
you were doing heroin?
- Hm mm, yeah.
I was doing heroin and I was homeless,
I was just like
doing random boosting or whatever.
I had had a boyfriend
who had taken care of
me for a long time so.
- [Interviewer] What age
were you when you started?
- I was 16 when I started heroin,
I was 14 when I started getting high.
- [Interviewer] Tell me
about your childhood.
- I grew up really, really poor.
I'm the oldest of five kids.
My dad is an alcoholic,
my mom is a drug addict
and they were really, really absent
as we were growing up like..
I raised my siblings like
until I was like 18 and I left.
I was the one who like got them up
for school in the mornings,
made sure they ate dinner,
when we had food I'd
make sure they ate dinner
Yeah.
- [Interviewer] You were a
teenager, you were the parent.
- Yeah, yeah, definitely.
My parents, basically
after the kids were like
newborns or whatever like they would just
stop showing up at home like
like for days at a time
we couldn't find them.
Like the power would get shut off
every month after like about a week or so
cause my grandparents would..
We'd have to call my
grandparents cause like
we'd be like literally starving
and like we wouldn't know where they were
so we'd have to call my grandparents,
they would track down my parents
my parents would come
back for like a few days
play the parent role or whatever
and then disappear again
for the rest of the month.
So..
Yep.
- [Interviewer] Do you still have contact
with your siblings?
- Um, not really just
cause I'm getting high
and I don't want.. I've
like cause enough like
turmoil and like heartbreak and
like worry in their lives,
like not until I get sober again.
- [Interviewer] Right.
Where are you staying now?
Where do you sleep?
- I stay in a tent off of Crocker and 7th.
- [Interviewer] Are you?
- Yeah, um, I was staying
off 6th and St. Julian
and then about a month ago
my boyfriend went to jail
and then I went to jail about two days..
a day later or whatever.
And then when I got out, all
our stuff was gone again so.
I got a new tent and then
I put it up over there.
So..
- [Interviewer] And then, what
are you doing for money now?
- Working the street.
- [Interviewer] You
typically do that at night
or during the day or?
- At night, at night mostly, yeah.
- [Interviewer] And how much
money do you make in a night?
- Like nothing (chuckling)
like about...
Like on a really good night,
I'll make like 120 bucks.
On like a usual night
downtown, I'll make like
50, 60 bucks, that's it.
- [Interviewer] And
you make sure everybody
is using condoms and--
- Always, always.
I don't wanna,
I would say I don't wanna
permanent consequence
off a temporary situation.
You know, I don't wanna
end up with HIV or AIDS.
I'm only 26.
Like I don't wanna end up with HIV
like I still have the rest
of my life you know like
and it's really prevalent down here.
I know like a couple
girls who have gotten HIV
like since I've been out here
and like, that's scary, that's horrible.
- [Interviewer] Where would you like to
be in five years you think?
And what would you like to see now?
- Five years I would like to be like
I don't know,
happy, just happy and comfortable
and like safe and secure like
that's really it.
Like I don't like care where I'm working
or what I'm doing as long
as I'm happy, you know.
And like around people who like
really genuinely care for me.
Cause around here, nobody
really cares about you.
People just want what they
can get from you and..
There's a price to pay for everything.
Nothing around here is
free, that's for sure.
Especially for--
- [Interviewer] What do
you think it is about
heroin addiction that blocks you from
getting your life together,
getting, taking some
responsibility, getting a job
getting a place to live,
getting a car or whatever.
Does it just drain your
energy to do that or you're..?
- No, it just, it always comes first,
because you get dope sick or whatever,
just no matter what, the
dope comes before everything
because you're just so
afraid of getting sick.
Because once you get
sick, then it's over with,
you can't function, you can't hustle,
you can't get money,
you can't do anything.
- [Interviewer] Can't get dressed.
- Yeah, you can't do anything.
Like you're literally like
horribly, horribly sick.
So you'll do anything to make sure
you don't get to that point.
So like, if you have
to go to work that day
and you're outta dope and you
don't get paid till Friday
you gotta figure out something today
like forget Friday, you know.
It's too much of a minute by minute,
day by day drug, you know.
- [Interviewer] Did you ever overdose?
- No, but I have like,
resuscitated and narcan
over like 15 people down here
since I've been down here.
- [Interviewer] Okay.
- Mm mm.
- [Interviewer] Now,
Fentanyl is that something
you have to worry about with heroin?
- Yeah, it's horrible,
cause these people like,
like I try to tell people like
Fentanyl in the hospital
is for patients who are
terminally ill, who are about to be..
About dying, who are dying and
about to be, you know, dead.
And, it's measured in micro grams,
it's not measured in regular grams like
people don't understand that,
and it's like an anesthetic
like a puts you asleep
or whatever for surgery.
It's like one of those drugs,
it's not meant to get high off of,
it's not, I've never watched
someone snort something
and overdosed.
Like that, that was crazy to me,
this guy snorted some of it and overdosed.
We had to narcan him and do CPR like
that was insane like
it's not something to mess around with
and then people are like playing chemistry
with the do..
With the heroin and
then putting it in there
to make it like a little bit stronger
so they can make more money
and it's killing people.
And they just don't care.
It blows my mind.
- [Interviewer] Did you
have dreams as a young girl
of doing something with your life?
- I did ballet for like 12 years.
And I always wanted to
got to like Julliard
or be a ballerina and then
if that didn't work out I
was gonna be a nurse and
like help people,
but I don't know, I just got so like
after like, like raising
my siblings and like
nobody told me like
hey, fill out these college applications
or hey take this test or
hey, take these classes.
I didn't have any guidance
or any sort of direction
so I didn't end up doing any of it
and then I ended up getting
like hooked on these drugs
and then after that it was a wrap.
It was just a wrap.
(sirens wailing)
- [Interviewer] Thank
you for talking to us.
- Thank you, thank you.
Thank you very much.
Thank you, it will be a bright one.
I've decided, it will be a bright one.
(chuckling)